all right you got
yes sir yes you got uh where'd you grow
up where are you from originally uh I'm
from Seattle Washington Seattle tell me
about your family you had both your
parents oh my family is uh fake they
never supported me
in what ways were they fake uh
uh when I like wear a girl clothes my
stepdad said oh you know going out what
do you wearing that a little change your
shirt
and this started at what age
oh actually that was like a 2019. how
old are you now I'm like 28 you're 28
yeah and my trans birthday is coming up
October 21st
so your family didn't it didn't approve
of your no actually I have until my
family and not uh trans and uh they
don't deserve to know that information
so this has been uh three years or so
that you've been no I left the my
homeland around like my soul car home in
around 2019.
it's about three years yeah
you came to La uh yeah I came to LA to
live with my mom and dad
or stepdad
it didn't work out and they used me for
like
rent money and stuff
how would you describe your childhood in
general my childhood was uh
different I guess
in what ways in life
I was just different like in
kindergarten they say oh arrest for
girls and I was like one of these red
earrings and I told my mom to take it
out
you always
felt more comfortable as a female
what you always felt more comfortable as
a female
oh I've I I feel like
it changed my life to be honest
I feel more comfortable now yeah
and it makes my skin really soft
what makes your skin soft all right the
estrogen oh you're taking the hormones
yes
had to get um my subscriptions and that
food until like October
so my like breasts have grown and stuff
since last time
and you're living on the streets here in
L.A uh I slept on the bridge what what's
my best friend
I'm not homeless though I live in Skid
Row but I'm gonna move to a different
shelter
[Music]
drugs a part of your life uh
sometimes Coke
uh or quite occasionally
every so often I mean uh LSD and
marijuana
I I haven't done SSC
in a while
last time I did sec I stood up all night
on the boulevard
trying to sell weed and stuff and you
can find LSD on the streets uh yeah
people just give it to me
sometimes
no all this one how do you support
yourself
uh SSI in like exercising
exercising yeah people pay you to
exercise no
I dislike the exercise
and let's think about life and stuff
like
no but how do you make enough money to
oh SSI okay
I I feel like I shouldn't worry about
money because I know my future is bright
I'm just taking baby steps that's all
so what are your plans for the future oh
my plans for future I can't I can't
dictate it dictate my future at all
and I'll just go with the flow because
if you think about the future too much
uh you you kind of mess it up for
yourself you just go with the flow and
that's how I that's how I um navigate
that's how you that's what you believe
that's how I navigate yes
that's interesting
and as far as becoming
more feminine are there other
procedures you want to have done
oh yeah like
another I looked up
the forehead surgery and I looked up how
they do it it's like some they like pull
your scalp back or whatever and then
looks like they chiseled the bone or
whatnot and somehow it's like it lowers
your your hairline yeah and then like
the the jaw whatever
in the nose
in the eyes
so you're looking to have all these
procedures done oh yeah and the voice
and the voice surgery to be more
effeminine and and then the Adam's apple
shaved or whatever
[Music]
do you still speak with your family uh I
feel like I shouldn't speak to them ever
again
did you ever have dreams of uh doing
anything as a career
yes um
I really don't know but I want to be a
model but I already know it like
you have to sell part of your soul too
or whatever
because I did a little research on it
so being a model you have to sell your
well as some like a part of your soul
not like selling it but I want somehow
to like like
because my friend has like a a movie uh
business or whatever and they want to
sign me and stuff so I could do that
instead
because I have a talent
yes I have a lot of face tattoos yes yes
I love facetimes
[Music]
tell me about your face tattoos oh this
is Priscilla from my favorite anime uh
Claymore
and her name is Priscilla and she got
her hair cut off whatever
and she was uh the villain
and uh and the anime that has human
power and she fully awakened her power
and she grew like big ass wings and
stuff and she was eating humans on the
uh anime
and this is uh Aphrodite she was born on
Monday like me
and this is my most recent one it says
unapproachable
and this is Medusa right here and
vampire
then leave forever V for Vendetta
uh Priscilla again
then I have China and Asia and Japan
however much more
do you have friends uh
[Music]
uh amber crazy
Emmy cat
and like internet friends
I really don't have friends like that
though
but I have a a Baja Blast shoddy God I
mean it's quitter he changed his name to
it's quitter
uh Sicky my tattoo artist
what emotions do you go through living
this lifestyle uh it's uh
uh I overthink a lot in this a lot of
emotions I guess
let's allow your emotions
Mr angry or one of my friends is in a
coma and I feel
devastated I don't want him to die
because I used to live with him his
name's atrial
I don't want him to like
why is he in a coma I don't know he was
found unconscious and it's uh
it's I've been losing rest over it
but I got arrested last night though
would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
uh
I'm just so destructive mean
like you'll you'll do things too
get in the way of your own
happiness or advancement
by getting a face full of tattoos might
slow you down a little bit in terms of
being a model no actually uh
I love my face tattoos now I understand
you love them yeah but you have to
understand that they they might get in
the way of I'll I'll just figure uh
something out I can just go uh do acting
with my friend
I can work with my friends and said
because they know my friend that uh so
overdose yourself off Coke he makes his
coke uh cookware Fentanyl and he
self-overdosed and I heard it from her
his girlfriend
what are you afraid of uh
I'm afraid of
losing my best friend
ah
do you think you're misunderstood by
most people uh most of the population
yeah
does that trouble you or you're
comfortable with it uh it doesn't
trouble me because you throw out I don't
have haters you're not doing it right
if you had your life to live all over
again are there any things you would
have done differently
no
you got what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
always cheers to people that um care
about you
because I have a lot of people that care
about me
it's great
all right you got thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you thank you
appreciate you be careful out there all
right